I I actually haven't skated yet because
I hyper extended my elbow with the bone
sticking out my arm is still crooked and
I broke my wrist for the 15th time so I
haven't been like ready to skate yet was
that the video that you posted where you
broke it yeah and it was just a four
foot mini ramp but some little [__] ass
waxed a half pipe covering like a
[__] Eskimo Iceberg and of course
like an idiot I don't practice and do a
couple 50 50s or fakey rocks first I
just dropped in right to a pop shove it
till start a revert when I revert it
slipped out so bad I went and like all
my weight went on my elbow and it bent
back the wrong way and then of course my
wrist got broken for the 15th time as
well so my wrist was in the shape of an
S and then the bone was sticking out of
my hyperextended elbows I'm trying to
make it to the hospital
they had to give me Pro propofol and
[__] to kill Michael Jackson to kill the
pain was that was that in Florida yeah I
think that was on TMZ too that's been a
while since then yeah
um
and uh I mean whatever it did like
skateboarding there's
it's our love like but it's such a well
I also noticed that if you're any kind
of overweight whatsoever even if it's
five to ten pound I mean picture trying
to kick flip a pyramid that you could do
first try holding two 10 pound weights
you're it's gonna take you 30 to 50
tries as you throw your board and get
frustrated so I don't want to begin
doing that again until I'm up to part of
the shaman said when he's done with me
because I committed to 90 days with him
he said I'm gonna look like a Greek
statue so I'm like all right then I'll
be ready to skate because I don't want
to be any kind of top heavy off balance
which is what the doctor in treatment
said he said if you're any kind of
depressed
um are you depressing like if I am any
kind of depressants because I'm top
heavy and I can't balance on the
skateboard how I used to and it's very
frustrating then I'm like eating salads
in there and either staying the same or
gaining weight and I was like that's it
then I type in Zyprexa Depakote and all
the other [__] that I was on and it
all said number one weight gaining pill
I'm like Doc why would you give me this
he's like well it's antidepressant I'm
like but if I keep getting fatter I'm
going to be more depressed you [__]
EI yeah
yeah and it doesn't make sense it's the
dumbest Catch 22 that well it's
antidepressant yeah but if I keep
getting fatter I'm going to be more
depressed right
so I don't want to take this and if I
don't comply then I could potentially do
another 90 days from not obeying the
doctors I'm done with it all I'm not on
anything now okay so so the uh have you
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
steamos butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude